Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
FLIRTATIONS ROCKED
SHANDI'S RELATIONSHIP...
Shandi: I HATE YOU.
Eric: I didn't--
I didn't know that!
Tyra: AND AN INSIGHTFUL PSYCHIC
SAW RIGHT THROUGH CAMILLE...
Suzannah: CAMILLE,
YOU PUT PEOPLE OFF.
Tyra: AND WHILE PERFORMING
IN MY MUSIC VIDEO,
YOANNA AND APRIL
FOUGHT FOR THE SPOTLIGHT.
Yoanna: I'M PISSED.
Tyra: FINALLY,
AT AN EMOTIONAL ELIMINATION...
Eric: SARA, FOR ME,
I'M STARTING TO FEEL THAT
SHE COULD BE GOING
WAY DOWN MARKET.
Tyra: IT WAS SARA
WHO WAS SENT HOME.
ONLY FIVE GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
Yoanna: THE LAST ELIMINATION
WE WERE ALL CRYING BECAUSE SARA
WAS CHOSEN TO BE ELIMINATED.
IT WAS JUST A LOT, YOU KNOW?
I RECENTLY
LOST A LOT OF WEIGHT.
IT WAS ABOUT 45 POUNDS.
I MIGHT FEEL A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH MY BODY,
AND I DON'T WANT THAT TO BE
A REASON THAT I WOULD EVER
GET ELIMINATED.
Camille: I GOT, YOU KNOW,
WHAT SHE SAID ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
"FIND A FRIEND
IN CELEBRATING..."
THE PSYCHIC WHO CAME
TO OUR HOUSE TOLD US,
"OH, CAMILLE, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE NOT GONNA WIN
THIS COMPETITION
UNLESS YOU OPEN UP AND YOU
BECOME FRIENDS WITH PEOPLE."
Mercedes: YOU NEED TO TAKE
HER WORDS AND THINK ABOUT WHAT
SHE SAID AND THEN REALLY
APPLY IT TO HOW YOU ARE.
Camille: I'LL NEVER BE
THE PERSON TO MAKE UP
A FRIENDSHIP FOR ANYBODY,
BUT I'LL DO WHATEVER IT TAKES
TO WIN.
Mercedes: I'M NOT PLAYING
PEACEMAKER, BUT I JUST--
I WANT ALL THE ARGUING
AND BICKERING TO STOP
BETWEEN YOANNA AND CAMILLE.
Camille: TRUST ME.
IF I HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY--
Yoanna: I DON'T TRUST YOU.
I JUST REALLY THINK
THAT A LOT OF TIMES
CAMILLE IS A VERY LONELY GIRL.
I THINK SHE WANTS TO HAVE
FRIENDS, BUT I THINK SHE PUTS
A FRONT THAT SHE'S TOUGH.
Yoanna: IT'S NOT THAT
I'M SAYING SHE'S A BAD PERSON.
I NEVER SAID THAT,
BUT I KNOW SHE'S NEEDY,
AND I DON'T THINK SHE'S FELT
THE LOVE THAT SHE'S NEEDED.
Mercedes: SHE JUST WANTS TO,
LIKE, FEEL WANTED, YOU KNOW?
AND ESPECIALLY BY YOU.
♪♪♪
Mercedes: WE GOT TYRA MAIL.
OH, MY GOD.
"IT'S TIME TO HEAD TO
HEIDI, GISELE'S AND MY HOUSE."
HEIDI AND GISELE!
Yoanna: GISELE BUNDCHEN! OH!
OH, MY GOSH.
WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA GET TO MEET
GISELE AND HEIDI KLUM.
IT'S FOR REAL, SHANDI!
WE'RE MEETING THE BIG ONES.
Mercedes: THE TYRA MAIL SAYS
COME TO TYRA'S HOUSE
TO MEET GISELE AND HEIDI,
AND I'M THINKING,
WE'RE GONNA MEET
THOSE TWO SUPERMODELS?
Yoanna: MORNING!
Kyle: GOOD MORNING, GUYS.
THIS IS THE HOME OF TYRA,
HEIDI, GISELE.
Mercedes: I WAS LIKE,
OH. (chuckles) OKAY. I GET IT.
IT'S IMG, AND THIS IS HUGE,
BECAUSE THIS IS THE AGENCY
THAT WHOEVER WINS THIS
IS GONNA HAVE A CONTRACT WITH.
Kyle: WE SEE A HUNDRED PEOPLE
ON A DAILY BASIS.
OF THE HUNDRED PEOPLE,
WE ONLY SIGN
APPROXIMATELY TWO A YEAR.
SO... (chuckles)
Shandi: IT'S SO CRAZY,
THAT YOU HAVE TO STAND OUT
THAT MUCH.
Kyle: ON A GO-SEE...
Shandi: A GO-SEE--
IT'S JUST LIKE GOING
ON AN INTERVIEW FOR A JOB.
Kyle: NOBODY CARES
WHO YOU ARE,
AND YOU'VE GOTTA MAKE THEM CARE.
YOU'VE GOTTA MAKE THEM WANT YOU
IN A MINUTE.
LET'S SAY I'M DOING
AN ADVERTISING JOB
FOR A MAJOR FASHION HOUSE.
HOW OLD ARE YOU?
April: 23.
Kyle: WHERE ARE YOU FROM?
Mercedes: VALENCIA,
CALIFORNIA.
Kyle: WHO'S
YOUR FAVORITE PHOTOGRAPHER?
Yoanna: CRAIG McDEAN.
Kyle: WHY DO YOU WANNA
WORK FOR ME?
Camille: I LOVE THE STYLE
AND DESIGN OF YOUR CLOTHING.
Kyle: THAT'S HOW
THE GO-SEES ARE GONNA GO.
IT'S JUST KEY THAT YOU GIVE THEM
YOUR ALL.
CONGRATULATIONS ON GETTING
TO THIS POINT.
Shandi: THANK YOU.
♪♪♪
Yoanna: COME ON, CAMILLE,
LET'S DO OUR FIRST CONFESSION
TOGETHER.
April: HONESTLY, I, LIKE,
DON'T KNOW WHEN IT HAPPENED,
BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN,
YOANNA AND CAMILLE ARE, LIKE,
FRIENDS.
Yoanna: WELL, HELLO,
MISS DIANA ROSS, YOU'VE ARRIVED.
NOW HOW ARE YOU TAKING
THIS CITY?
IS THIS SPACE ENOUGH ROOM
FOR YOU?
Camille: OH,
ARE YOU TALKING TO ME?
I'M SO SORRY.
Yoanna: SO WHAT DO YOU THINK
MR. IMG MAN--DO YOU THINK
HE'S GONNA PUT US
IN AN EBONY AND IVORY CAMPAIGN?
Camille: HE BETTER,
BECAUSE IF HE DOESN'T,
WE'LL JUST HAVE TO SCARE
THE HELL OUT OF HIM, YOU KNOW?
YOANNA, I LOVE YOU!
GIVE ME SOME LOVE!
Yoanna: (laughing)
SOME DAYS I LOVE YOU, TOO.
WELL, OFF WE GO TO LUNCH
IN LITTLE ITALY.
EBONY AND IVORY'S
FIRST CONFESSIONAL TOGETHER.
♪♪♪
Mercedes: OH,
THAT LOOKS GOOD.
Yoanna: AAH!
Tyra: AAH!
HI, LADIES.
April: HI.
Tyra: SO WHAT'D YOU GUYS
DO TODAY?
OH, YOU WENT TO MY HOUSE.
Yoanna: YEAH.
Tyra: Y'ALL WENT TO MY HOUSE.
HOW WAS IT?
Camille: IT WAS FABULOUS.
Tyra: MISS CAMILLE,
YOU GOT ON TOO MUCH MAKEUP.
Camille: I DO?
Tyra: YEAH!
AS A MODEL, YOU GUYS WANNA
KINDA BE A CLEAN PALETTE
WHEN YOU'RE WALKING AROUND.
YOU GUYS ALL ARE
NATURALLY BEAUTIFUL.
YOU DON'T NEED ALL THAT STUFF.
Mercedes: CAN YOU FLOW, TYRA?
Tyra: CAN I FLOW? CAN I RAP?
OKAY, I HAVE A RAP.
Mercedes: OKAY, HERE IT GOES.
Tyra: I WROTE IT
IN THE NINTH GRADE...
(laughter)
Tyra: IN ALGEBRA 1 CLASS.
Shandi: OH.
Tyra: OKAY?
♪ UNH-UNH-UNH ♪
♪ I'M 34C WITH NO SILI-CONE ♪
♪ TAKE A PILL
AND YOU WILL SEE ♪
♪ I'M 5 FOOT 9,
I LOOK SO FINE ♪
♪ YES, ALL MY FELLAS
ARE SO DIVINE ♪
♪ WHEN I'M FINISHED
WITH THIS ♪
♪ YOU MIGHT AS WELL
JUST DISMISS ♪
♪ ALL THE OTHER FEMALE RAPPERS
'CAUSE Y'ALL JUST PISSED ♪
♪ TOP MODELS, PACK QUICK
ON THE ROAD, ALWAYS GONE ♪
♪ PACK YOUR BAGS, Y'ALL ♪
♪ YOU'RE GOING TO
TO MILAN! ♪♪
Women: (screaming)
Mercedes: AND I'M LIKE,
HA HA!
THAT'S WHERE I WANTED TO GO.
THIS IS WHERE I WANTED TO GO
MY WHOLE LIFE--IS MILAN, ITALY.
AS A MODEL, GETTING THIS TYPE
OF INFORMATION--IT'S...
I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S PROBABLY BETTER THAN SEX,
SO... NAH. NO, YEAH.
WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
Tyra: YOU ARE GONNA FEEL
SO DAMN FINE AND AMAZING,
'CAUSE EVERY SINGLE MAN
YOU WALK BY IS LIKE,
"CIAO, BELLA!
OH, DONNA BELLA!
OOH, GRAZIE, BABY, COME HERE!"
Yoanna: I'M EXCITED
TO GO TO MILAN
BECAUSE IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY
TO LOOK INTO THE MARKET
AND KINDA STUDY IT
AS FAR AS FASHION,
AND THE BOYS ARE DELICIOUS.
Tyra: IN THE FASHION
INDUSTRY, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S TOKYO, THERE'S MIAMI,
THERE'S L.A.,
BUT IN MILAN, YOU GUYS,
IT'S ALL ABOUT HIGH FASHION.
YOU CAN'T JUST BE
SOFT AND PRETTY OVER THERE.
YOU'VE GOTTA BE REALLY EDGY.
Shandi: I'VE NEVER BEEN
OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
Tyra: WOW!
Shandi: I'M PRETTY MUCH
IN SHOCK.
I'M JUST LIKE... OKAY!
LET'S GO.
LET'S GO NOW.
Tyra: YOU GUYS HAVE TO BE
PACKED AND READY TO LEAVE
IN ONE HOUR.
♪♪♪
Yoanna: I'M JUST TRYING
TO THINK OF ALL THE SCENARIOS
THAT COULD POSSIBLY POP UP
WHILE BEING IN MILAN.
Mercedes: PHYSICALLY,
THIS COMPETITION
HAS BEEN DRAINING.
LUPUS GOES THROUGH
REMISSIONS AND FLARES.
I'M TRYING NOT TO THINK
ABOUT THAT, BECAUSE I JUST
WANNA MAKE IT AS FAR
IN THIS COMPETITION AS I CAN.
Shandi: I CAN'T BE ON HERE
VERY LONG, BUT I JUST NEED
TO TELL YOU THAT I'M GONNA BE
LEAVING FOR A LITTLE WHILE.
NO?
MY BOYFRIEND, YOU KNOW,
DEEP DOWN
IS PROBABLY THINKING, LIKE,
"OH, SHE'S DOING HER OWN THING.
SHE'S JUST GONNA
LEAVE ME BEHIND."
Eric: All right, bye.
Shandi: I LOVE YOU.
Eric: I love you, too. Bye.
Yoanna: HEAVENLY FATHER,
WE ASK THAT YOU BLESS
ALL OUR LUGGAGE
AND ARRIVE SAFELY AND ON TIME,
IN JESUS' NAME
WE ASK THESE THINGS.
BLESS OUR LORD. AMEN.
♪♪♪
Man: WELCOME TO MILAN.
I'VE GOT SOMETHING FOR YOU.
IT'S THIS ONE.
Yoanna: TYRA MAIL.
Shandi: OHH!
Yoanna: I'LL READ IT.
Camille: "BUON GIORNO.
WELCOME TO MILAN.
YOUR ADVENTURE BEGINS
AT MY ITALIAN MODELING AGENCY,
D'MANAGEMENT GROUP."
I'VE BEEN DREAMING ABOUT
COMING TO MILAN
NOT JUST TO COME HERE
BUT COMING HERE
AND PURSUING FASHION.
Yoanna: I'M SO EXCITED
TO BE HERE, AND I KNOW THAT I'M
JUST A "TOP MODEL IN TRAINING."
April: LOOK HOW CUTE
THE LITTLE CARS ARE HERE.
Shandi: THE SCENERY
IS UNBELIEVABLE.
IT'S JUST SO BEAUTIFUL.
I JUST CAN'T STOP, LIKE,
LOOKING OUT THE WINDOW,
EVEN THOUGH I'M SO TIRED
AND I'M SO HUNGRY.
Yoanna: OH, MY GOD.
David: HI, GIRLS.
WELCOME TO MILAN.
I HOPE YOU HAD
A GOOD FLIGHT.
MY NAME IS DAVID BROWN,
AND THIS IS D'MANAGEMENT GROUP.
D'MANAGEMENT IS
A RATHER SPECIAL AGENCY.
IT'S AN AGENCY THAT REPRESENTS
EXCLUSIVELY TOP MODELS
IN THE WORLD,
SUCH AS TYRA BANKS,
KATE MOSS, ANGELA LINDVALL.
Mercedes: I'M LOOKING AROUND,
LOOKING AT ALL
THESE SUPERMODELS,
LOOKING AT THE PICTURES
ON THE WALL, LIKE,
I CAN DO THIS.
David: MILAN IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT
TRAINING GROUND IN THE WORLD
FOR MODELS.
TODAY YOU'RE ON FIVE GO-SEES.
AND WHAT IS A GO-SEE?
IT'S ACTUALLY GOING AND SEEING
A PROSPECTIVE CLIENT.
Shandi: THIS DAY
IS GOING REALLY, REALLY FAST.
WE DON'T GET TO REST.
WE DON'T GET TO DO ANYTHING.
WE ARE GOING
STRAIGHT TO WORK.
David: YOU'LL BE SEEING
CLIENTS WHERE YOU'LL BE
DISPLAYING SOME ASPECTS
OF BEING A TOP MODEL--
YOUR APPEARANCE,
YOUR PERSONALITY,
YOUR PROFESSIONALITY
AND YOUR CONFIDENCE.
I'LL BE SEEING YOU BACK HERE
AT THE END OF THE DAY
TO JUDGE WHO IS THE WINNER.
HERE ARE YOUR BOOKS.
NOW FOLLOW ME.
Shandi: IT'S REALLY COOL
TO SEE YOUR PICTURES,
AND, LIKE, YOUR PORTFOLIO--
IT'S STARTING
TO BECOME SOMETHING.
Camille: MY ATTITUDE IS
WALK TO THE BEST OF MY ABILITY,
SHOW CONFIDENCE AND WIN.
Mercedes: I'VE GOT
MY ITALIAN BOOK.
I'VE GOT MY HIGH HEELS
IN MY BAG.
I GOT MY MAKEUP ON.
MY HAIR'S A LITTLE BIT
MESSED UP, BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M GOING OUT THERE
AND I'M READY TO WIN
THIS COMPETITION.
David: HERE'S HOW YOU'RE
GONNA BE GETTING AROUND MILAN.
♪♪♪
April: WOW. (laughs)
Mercedes: AS FAR AS
WHAT I CAN SEE, I LIKE...
Man: CIAO.
Mercedes: I LIKE A LOT.
April: OH, WOW. (laughs)
Man #2: CIAO.
Man #3: CIAO.
Men: CIAO.
Women: CIAO.
Yoanna: SO FIVE VESPAS
PULL UP, AND I'M JUST
WONDERING IN MY MIND
WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE THE ONES
THAT HAVE TO DRIVE.
Man: CIAO.
Man #2: CIAO.
Men: CIAO.
Women: CIAO.
David: THIS IS HOW
YOU'LL BE GETTING AROUND MILAN.
NOW COME AND CHOOSE YOUR DRIVER.
Mercedes: OUR CHALLENGE
IS GOING ON FIVE GO-SEES.
THE CRITERIA FOR THE CONTEST
IS APPEARANCE, CONFIDENCE,
PERSONALITY AND PROFESSIONALISM.
Man: CIAO, DONNA.
Man #2: LET'S GO.
Yoanna: LET'S GO.
(horn honks)
Mercedes: IDIOTE.
April: WHOO.
Shandi: THIS IS NICE.
Man #3: YES.
Camille: MY MOM--
SHE SPEAKS ITALIAN FLUENTLY
ONLY BECAUSE WHEN SHE CAME HERE
FOR THE FIRST TIME,
SHE MET A GUY.
(laughing)
♪♪♪
Yoanna: THIS IS SOMETHING
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED
SINCE I WAS A LITTLE GIRL.
I, LIKE, HAD THIS DREAM
FOR MYSELF THAT I WANTED TO BE
A PART OF, YOU KNOW,
THE FASHION WORLD.
Woman: HOW LONG
HAVE YOU BEEN MODELING FOR?
Yoanna: UM, FOR ABOUT, OOH,
FOUR MONTHS.
Elena: RIGHT.
WE CAN HAVE A POLAROID.
WHAT YOU THINK?
YOANNA--I THINK SHE WAS
REALLY ELEGANT,
BUT SHE WAS KIND OF STRANGE.
LIKE, HER SHOULDER
AND THE BREAST--
SHE WAS TOO... SQUARE.
Yoanna: THEY'RE ALWAYS
LOOKING FOR DIFFERENT THINGS,
BUT IT'S HARD TO TELL
WHETHER I DID WELL OR NOT.
Shandi: OH, MY GOODNESS.
MILAN, TO ME, IS, LIKE,
UNBELIEVABLE.
EVERYTHING IS JUST
A MILLION TIMES NICER.
Marcella: CAN YOU WALK
FOR ME?
Shandi: SURE.
DO YOU WANT ME TO POSE
OR ANYTHING AT THE...
Marcella: NO. BE SEXY.
Shandi: JUST BE SEXY?
Marcella: YEAH.
Shandi: OKAY.
Marcella: THANK YOU.
Shandi: MY VERY FIRST
GO-SEE, SO DID IT GO GOOD OR...
Marcella: YEAH.
Shandi: OKAY.
♪♪♪
Camille: SO YOU DON'T HAVE
A WIFE?
DO YOU HAVE KIDS?
Man: I LIVE ALONE.
HAVE YOU GOT A BOYFRIEND?
Camille: (laughing)
Camille: FIX MY HAIR.
OKAY, SEE YOU IN A MINUTE,
RIGHT?
Man: GOOD LUCK. CIAO.
Camille: OKAY. THANK YOU.
Carlo: YOU KNOW THAT
THIS IS THE NUMBER-ONE AGENCY,
SO WE USE REALLY TOP MODEL.
Camille: OKAY,
SO I'M IN THE RIGHT PLACE.
Carlo: YOU THINK SO, HUH?
Camille: I JUST PUT ON
MY PERSONALITY
AND MADE IT A POINT
TO GET A BUSINESS CARD
AND LEAVE THE WINDOW
OF OPPORTUNITY OPEN.
Carlo: CAMILLA--SHE HAS
A STRONG ATTITUDE INSIDE.
Camille: THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
Man: OKAY.
♪♪♪
Mercedes: OKAY.
NO ES BUENO.
(horn honks)
Mercedes: WELL, I FEEL LIKE
I'M IN, LIKE, AN ACTION MOVIE
WHERE YOU KNOW YOU'RE ALMOST
ABOUT TO DIE, BUT YOU DON'T.
DO YOU DO A LOT OF MAGAZINES?
Elena: ACTUALLY,
IT'S A WEEKLY FASHION MAGAZINE.
Mercedes: THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
A CLASSIC, ELEGANT TYPE OF LOOK.
I NEED TO, LIKE, LEARN
HOW TO BE MORE EDGY.
Elena: MERCEDES--I LIKE HER.
SHE HAS A NICE ATTITUDE,
BUT SHE WAS A LITTLE COMMERCIAL
FOR ME.
Camille: ARE YOU COLD?
Man: NO.
Camille: NO? YOU SURE?
Man: NEXT TO YOU, NO.
Camille: (chuckles)
'CAUSE I HAVE A WARM HEART.
Man #2: OKAY.
April: THANK YOU.
FOR ME, GO-SEE WAS
BUSINESS MODE.
I'M HERE TO SELL MYSELF.
Kesia: AND YOU'RE
MIXED-BLOODED, NO?
April: YES.
Kesia: I SEE THAT.
SO WHERE ARE YOUR ORIGINS?
April: MY MOM IS JAPANESE...
Kesia: YEAH.
April: AND MY FATHER IS
GERMAN, IRISH, SCOTTISH
AND WELSH.
♪♪♪
Mercedes: THIS IS HOW I FEEL
WHEN I HAVE A WEAVE,
AND I CAN'T SCRATCH MY HEAD.
COME ON, PRETTY BOY. LET'S GO.
MY LITTLE ITALIAN MAN--
HE REALLY DOESN'T SPEAK
THAT MUCH ENGLISH,
BUT OTHER THAN THAT,
I'M HAVING FUN.
Yoanna: MY MOM
IS FROM MEXICO.
MY FATHER'S CANADIAN.
AND I LOVE CHILDREN.
Camille: HAVE YOU EVER GRACED
ANY OF THE COVERS YOURSELF?
Mercedes: THE FIRST STEP
IN BELLY DANCING
IS THE FIGURE 8,
SO YOU GO LIKE THIS.
AND THEN THE MOVEMENT
IS LIKE THIS, BUT WHEN YOU HAVE
THE--LIKE SHAKIRA.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU HAVE
THE THING, AND IT'S LIKE...
♪♪♪
(horn honks)
Camille: LAST STOP.
LET'S MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
Liliana: YOUR NAME?
Camille: CAMILLE.
Liliana: (speaks Italian)
Man: (Italian accent)
WHY DID YOU COME WITH MAKEUP?
Camille: I'M COMING FROM
NEW YORK FROM ANOTHER JOB.
Liliana: (speaks Italian)
Man: AND SHE WOULD LIKE YOU
TO TRY THIS ON.
Liliana: QUICKLY, PLEASE.
Man: IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR FASHION SHOWS THAT YOU LEARN
HOW TO CHANGE VERY QUICKLY.
SHE THINKS THAT THAT'S NOT GOOD
TO HAVE THESE...
Liliana: I WANT TO SEE YOU.
Man: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU CALL THESE THINGS.
Mercedes: WHAT MADE ME
NERVOUS WAS HER ATTITUDE.
I FELT LIKE I WAS HER BITCH
OR SOMETHING.
Man: NO, NO, NO, NO.
CLOTHES. OKAY, GO.
Man: OKAY, SHE WANTS TO KNOW
WHY YOU WALK LIKE THIS.
EXPLAIN. EXPLAIN.
TRY TO EXPLAIN.
Camille: THIS IS
MY SIGNATURE WALK, AND THIS IS
WHAT'S GOING TO MAKE ME FAMOUS.
Man: DO YOU HAVE EXPERIENCE?
NO? OKAY.
Liliana: YOU CAN CHANGE.
BYE.
Yoanna: THE LADY WAS TOUGH,
BUT I'M NOT GONNA GO CRY
IN A CORNER OR ANYTHING.
Man: WHY SHOULD SHE TAKE YOU
WITH AS LITTLE EXPERIENCE
LIKE YOU DO?
Shandi: IF SHE WERE TO SEE
SOMETHING IN ME...
Man: (speaks Italian)
Liliana: THANK YOU. GRAZIE.
Shandi: SHE IS A MEANIE,
AND SHE IS A BAD WOMAN,
AND I DON'T LIKE HER.
Man: IN YOUR PICTURES,
WHAT DO YOU PORTRAY?
QUICK, PLEASE.
April: TRANQUILITY.
Man: MOLTO TRANQUILLA.
April: SEX APPEAL.
Man: (speaks Italian)
CAN YOU--CAN YOU FIX YOURSELF
OUTSIDE, PLEASE?
Camille: I'M FINISHED.
Man: OKAY.
Camille: IT WAS A BIT COARSE,
BUT I'M SURE THAT CARACTèRE
WILL BE CALLING ME
PRETTY SOON,
SO IT'S NOT A PROBLEM.
I'VE MET WORSE.
♪♪♪
Man: IT'S VERY FAMOUS
IN MILAN.
HERE. LOOK AT THAT.
Camille: WOW.
THAT'S GORGEOUS. PRETTY.
BELLA.
Camille: THEY LIKED MY WALK,
WHICH IS GOOD.
Man: VERY DIFFERENT.
Camille: (giggling)
Camille: THANK YOU.
SAME TO YOU.
Camille: A VERY NICE MAN
WANTED TO WIN MY HEART,
AND I'M HAPPY WITH THAT.
♪♪♪
Yoanna: OH! HELLO.
Mercedes: AFTER DOING
ALL THE GO-SEES,
WE GO BACK TO D'MANAGEMENT
TO MEET WITH TYRA AND DAVID.
Tyra: WHAT WAS
THE HARDEST THING FOR YOU GUYS?
Shandi: YOU'RE NEW
AND YOU'RE LEARNING--
THAT WAS THE HARDEST PART.
Tyra: WHAT WAS
THE EASIEST PART?
April: THE VESPA.
Tyra: THE VESPA! VROOM!
WHEN I USED TO HAVE
A LOT OF FASHION SHOWS,
THEY WOULD THROW YOU
ON THE BACKSEAT OF THAT VESPA
WITH THAT PRETTY ITALIAN BOY.
I HAVE YOUR RESULTS
FROM YOUR GO-SEES.
WITH SHANDI, YOU ARE MORE
FASHION THAN COMMERCIAL.
YOU ARE WAY TOO SHY
AND NOT SELF-CONFIDENT.
Shandi: MM.
Tyra: APRIL, THEY SAID
THAT YOU ARE VERY STRONG
IN APPEARANCE BUT WEAK
IN ALL OF THE OTHER AREAS.
YOANNA, THEY SAID THAT YOU HAD
A REALLY GORGEOUS FACE,
BUT THAT YOU HAD TO WORK
ON YOUR BODY.
THEY AREN'T SO SURE YOU HAVE
A BODY FOR HIGH FASHION.
MERCEDES, THEY SAID
THAT WHEN YOU WALKED IN,
YOU WERE VERY WEAK
IN YOUR APPEARANCE BUT STRONG
AND A VERY CONFIDENT PERSON.
CAMILLE, THEY SAID THAT
YOUR LOOK MAY BE
A LITTLE TOO CLASSIC
AND STANDARD, BUT THAT YOU HAVE
THE BEST CONFIDENCE OVERALL.
THEY GAVE YOU SCORES
FROM 1 TO 10.
WHO THINKS THEY WON?
YOU THINK SHANDI WON?
Yoanna: SHANDI HAS THE BODY
TO BE A FASHION MODEL,
AND WE'RE IN MILAN,
AND THAT'S THE LOOK.
Shandi: THIS ONE OR THIS ONE?
I THINK IT'S GONNA BE
EITHER MERCEDES OR CAMILLE.
THEIR CRITIQUES WERE, LIKE,
ALL ABOUT CONFIDENCE.
Tyra: THE PERSON THAT HAD
THE HIGHEST SCORE WAS...
CAMILLE.
Shandi: SEE? I WAS RIGHT.
Tyra: CAMILLE WON!
YOU SOLD YOURSELF
AT THE GO-SEES.
Mercedes: YAY, CAMILLE.
CAMILLE IS VERY EXCITED,
BECAUSE SHE HASN'T WON
A CONTEST YET.
Tyra: YOU'RE GONNA GET
YOUR PORTRAIT DONE
BY AN ITALIAN ARTIST,
AND YOU GET TO CHOOSE ONE PERSON
TO GO ALONG WITH YOU TO GET
THEIR PORTRAIT DONE, TOO.
Camille: YOANNA.
Tyra: YOANNA, YOU GUYS
ARE GONNA BE DONE.
Yoanna: OKAY, COOL. THANKS.
April: IT FEELS GOOD
TO SEE THEM FRIENDS.
IT FEELS LIKE WE'VE COME
FULL CIRCLE.
Camille: YOANNA--
SHE HAS AN ISSUE WITH HERSELF,
CONFIDENCE, AND I CHOSE HER
BECAUSE I WANTED HER
TO ACTUALLY SEE THAT
SHE IS GORGEOUS.
Yoanna: I WAS GONNA SAY,
IN REGARDS--WHEN THEY SAID
WORK ON THE BODY, LIKE,
DO THEY MEAN, LIKE, TONING OR...
Tyra: PROBABLY, YEAH.
Yoanna: 'CAUSE I'M ALREADY
A SIZE 2.
I MEAN...
Mercedes: IT IS HARD
FOR YOANNA TO TAKE IN
ALL THAT INFORMATION
ABOUT HER BODY BECAUSE
THAT'S SO SENSITIVE.
YOU'RE LIKE,
"WHAT'S WRONG WITH ME?"
David: AFTER A LONG DAY,
I'M SURE YOU WANNA GO
AND GET SOME REST.
I HAVE THE KEYS
TO YOUR MODEL APARTMENT.
Yoanna: IT'S REALLY COOL
THAT CAMILLE CHOSE ME,
BUT HONESTLY, IT DID UPSET ME
WITH THE CRITICISM
THAT I DON'T HAVE THE BODY TYPE.
I PROBABLY WON'T BE ABLE
TO BE A TOP MODEL.
Mercedes: ARE YOU UPSET?
Yoanna: IT'S TOO MUCH,
YOU KNOW?
IT'S TIME TO GO HOME.
Yoanna: I'M UPSET BECAUSE
THE CLIENTS SAID THAT I
PROBABLY DON'T HAVE THE BODY
TO BE A TOP MODEL.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
I'VE HEARD OF IT, OTHER THAN
HAVING TO DO MORE TONING.
Mercedes: YOANNA'S FEELING
SELF-CONSCIOUS, AND IT'S GONNA
HURT HER IN THE LONG RUN
IN THE MODELING INDUSTRY.
Shandi: I KNOW THAT
YOANNA WANTS THIS THING
MORE THAN ANYTHING,
BUT IT'S, LIKE, SLOWLY TAKING
ITS TOLL ON HER.
SHE'S HAD THIS CONSTANT BATTLE
WITH HER WEIGHT
AND TRYING TO LOOK LIKE A MODEL.
Mercedes: I WANNA GO TO BED.
I'VE HAD A LONG DAY.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO BECOME
A MODEL.
April: OOH. NICE.
Mercedes: WE GOT TYRA MAIL.
April: "MANY, MANY YEARS AGO
VERONA WAS THE HOME
OF ROMEO AND JULIET.
TOMORROW IT WILL BE THE HOME
OF YOUR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT
IN ITALY.
BE READY AT 7:30."
Camille: ROMEO AND JULIET?
April: VERONA'S BEAUTIFUL,
YOU GUYS.
WE'RE IN A SMALLER APARTMENT,
MUCH SMALLER,
IN A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENT.
WE'RE ALL HERE TO WIN,
AND I THINK EVERYONE KNOWS IT.
Mercedes: EW.
DON'T PUT YOUR SCARY BOYFRIEND
HERE.
Shandi: SHUT UP. HE'S NOT--
Mercedes: CAN'T YOU PUT IT
ON THE WALL OR SOMETHING?
Shandi: NO!
I HAVE, LIKE, A PIECE OF HOME
WITH ME.
I DON'T FEEL SO FAR AWAY
FROM MY BOYFRIEND.
Yoanna: WHO'D EVER THOUGHT
EBONY AND IVORY WOULD BE SHARING
A ROOM TOGETHER?
CAMILLE AND I ARE GETTING ALONG
A LOT MORE SO
THAN IN THE BEGINNING.
I WANNA KEEP PEACE.
Camille: THE BEST WAY
TO SEEK REVENGE ON SOMEONE
IS TO KILL 'EM WITH KINDNESS,
SO THAT'S WHAT I'M DOING.
I'M KILLING YOANNA
WITH KINDNESS.
♪♪♪
Shandi: WE KNOW THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE DOING
A PHOTO SHOOT TODAY--
OUR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT IN ITALY,
AND IT'S IN VERONA.
♪♪♪
Shandi: WOW.
Jay: HEY, GIRLS, OVER HERE!
YOU DIDN'T THINK I WAS GONNA
ABANDON YOU OUT HERE IN ITALY,
DID YOU?
YOU GUYS HAVE A GOOD TRIP?
Mercedes: YEAH.
Jay: SO THIS IS WHERE
WE'RE GONNA SHOOT TODAY.
THIS IS YOUR BACKDROP--
THE ARENA DI VERONA.
Shandi: BEAUTIFUL.
Jay: TODAY'S SHOOT
IS FOR SOLSTICE.
THEY ARE A HIGH-END RETAILER
OF LUXURY BRAND SUNGLASSES
IN AMERICA.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE WEARING DIOR.
WE ALSO HAVE MAX MARA,
BURBERRY, GUCCI
AND, OF COURSE, GIORGIO ARMANI.
NOW OUR PHOTOGRAPHER IS
MASSIMO COSTOLI.
SO, MASSIMO...
Massimo: HI.
Mercedes: HI.
Jay: NOW THE LOOK
OF TODAY'S SHOOT--
JUST SO YOU GET AN IDEA--
IT'S SUPPOSED TO LOOK LIKE
HIGH FASHION.
WE'VE GOTTA CREATE
AN AMAZING EDITORIAL
OF ALL FIVE OF YOU TODAY.
Yoanna: AFTER THE GO-SEES,
I'M DEFINITELY VERY AWARE
OF MY BODY.
I WANNA PROVE THAT
I CAN BE A HIGH FASHION MODEL.
Jay: SO LET'S WALK BACK DOWN
TO WARDROBE.
Shandi: WHOO-HOO.
Nolé: WE'RE GONNA SEE
WHICH ONE IS THE ABSOLUTE
MOST FABULOUS ON YOU.
Jay: OVER THE SHOULDER.
Nolé: FABULOUS. FABULOUS.
THAT IS CANDY. FABULOUS.
THOSE BOOTS ARE FABULOUS.
FABULOUS. STICK THIN.
YOU'RE A DESIGNER'S DREAM.
Jay: I SHOULD DO A WORD COUNT
HOW MANY TIMES
NOLé SAYS "FABULOUS" IN A DAY.
Nolé: WOW.
YOANNA LOOKS GREAT.
Jay: YOU FEEL PRETTY?
Yoanna: YEAH.
Jay: THAT'S A GOOD THING.
Yoanna: COUTURE.
Jay: YOU NEED
TO FEEL PRETTY.
Yoanna: IT'S A NEW MORNING.
I'M FEELING WELL-RESTED,
AND I DEFINITELY DO NOT
WANNA GO HOME.
Nolé: THESE, YOANNA,
ARE GONNA BE THE GLASSES
YOU'RE GONNA WEAR TODAY.
EXCELLENT.
Yoanna: DIOR.
Nolé: ABSOLUTELY. DIOR.
Yoanna: THEY GO
WITH THE DRESS--MR. GALLIANO.
Nolé: THAT'S IT.
Jay: AND YOU REMEMBER
THE POSES--KIND OF BENT OVER.
I ASKED ALL THE GIRLS TODAY
TO GIVE ME
VERY DECONSTRUCTED POSES
THAT ARE LIKE THIS.
THEY DON'T CARE.
'CAUSE MOST OF THE SHOOTS--
THEY'RE TENDING TO OVERTHINK
THEIR POSES, AND THEY'RE
A LITTLE STIFF ON SET.
Massimo: GOOD.
Yoanna: I FEEL LIKE
I AM LIVING THE TEEN DREAM.
I AM WEARING HAUTE COUTURE.
WHAT MORE
CAN A GIRL ASK FOR?
Jay: YOU JUST HAVE TO BE
A LITTLE MORE AWARE
OF YOUR FINGERS.
Massimo: THE FINGERS--
MORE NATURAL MOVEMENT
OF THE FINGERS.
Jay: YEAH.
Massimo: BRAVA.
April: SEE, THIS LOOKS LIKE
A REAL HIGH FASHION SHOOT.
Mercedes: I'M SIZING UP
MY COMPETITION
AND LOOKING AT HOW
THEY'RE PERFORMING,
AND IT IS SERIOUSLY
GIVING ME INSECURITIES.
Nolé: YOANNA--
SHE IS SLIGHTLY LARGER
THAN THE OTHER GIRLS,
BUT OVERALL,
SHE REALLY MOVED WELL.
Jay: THINK
MUCH MORE EDITORIAL.
IT'S NOT A POSE.
IT'S A RELAXED POSE.
Camille: I FEEL
VERY PRIVILEGED TO BE HERE
IN THIS SPOT,
EVEN QUITE ROYAL.
Massimo: I DON'T LIKE
TO FORCE IT.
Jay: DO YOU UNDERSTAND
WHY THAT LOOKS FORCED?
Massimo: THIS IS FORCED.
Jay: IF YOU'RE GONNA DO THIS,
IT DOESN'T--
IT NEEDS TO MEAN SOMETHING.
Massimo: STAY RIGHT THERE.
STAY.
DON'T CLOSE YOUR EYES.
LOOK MORE IN FRONT OF YOU.
Jay: DO YOU UNDERSTAND?
RELAX.
Massimo: THIS IS NICE.
Jay: CAMILLE OVERTHINKS
HER POSES.
SHE JUST NEVER LETS GO.
Shandi: I'M JUST
IN TOTAL AWE AND, LIKE, SHOCK
OF WHERE I'M AT.
IT'S GORGEOUS.
I'M NOT REALLY SURE
WHAT I'M DOING.
Massimo: DON'T MOVE.
THIS IS NICE. VERY NICE.
BELLA.
BELLA COS.
Jay: WHEN YOU TRY,
IT LOOKS AWKWARD.
WHEN YOU DON'T TRY,
IT LOOKS GOOD.
YEAH, THAT'S IT.
Shandi: OH, NOW I GET IT.
I'M NOT SUPPOSED TO, LIKE,
THINK ABOUT WHAT I'M DOING.
Jay: SHANDI--SHE LOOKS LIKE
SHE'S IN "ITALIAN VOGUE,"
PERIOD.
Nolé: HANDS DOWN, BABY.
Jay: I DON'T KNOW HOW
SHE CAME FROM WALGREENS TO THIS.
Nolé: THAT'S WHERE
THEY ALL COME FROM--
WALGREENS AND DAIRY QUEEN.
SHANDI COMPLETELY
BLEW ME AWAY.
FROM THE LAST TIME
I WORKED WITH HER,
SHE LOOKED LIKE SHE WAS
JUST ELECTRIFIED
WHEN PUT INTO THE WATER.
THIS TIME SHE CAME OUT
AS A TOTAL SUPERSTAR.
Massimo: BELLA COS.
NICE.
BRAVA.
April: I FELT LIKE THE SUN,
JUST LIKE
A FLAMING BALL OF FIRE,
AND I LOVE THAT BECAUSE
COLORS FUEL MY ENERGY.
THEY SET THE TONE FOR ME
ON A SHOOT.
Massimo: HOLD.
Nolé: THAT'S GOOD.
Jay: APRIL IS
VERY CONSISTENT.
APRIL CONTINUES TO DO
A GREAT JOB.
AND SO IF YOU WATCH MY BODY,
MY ARMS ARE HERE.
THEY'RE HUNCHED,
BUT IT'S LIKE I DON'T CARE.
IT'S LIKE, WHAT?
IT'S LIKE THIS.
Mercedes: I'M TRYING
NOT TO BE AS CUTE AND BUBBLY.
BEING CUTE IS A NERVOUS TWITCH
FOR ME.
LIKE, SMILING.
I HAVE A COMMERCIAL LOOK.
I NEED TO WORK ON BEING
MORE EDGY.
Jay: YOU GOTTA THINK OF
YOUR HIPS BEING TURNED UNDER.
I KNOW IT FEELS WEIRD,
BUT IT LOOKS GOOD.
YEAH, THAT'S IT.
April: THE WINNER
OF THIS COMPETITION NEEDS
TO BE ABLE TO DO COMMERCIAL
AND BE ABLE TO DO HIGH FASHION.
MERCEDES--I DON'T KNOW IF
SHE CAN PULL OFF HIGH FASHION.
Jay: SHE'S A BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
BUT I KEEP LOOKING AT MERCEDES,
THINKING THAT SHE'D BE
A TOOTHPASTE GIRL--
VERY COMMERCIAL.
Mercedes: THANK YOU.
IT WAS A PLEASURE.
Massimo: GOOD TO MEET YOU.
BRAVA.
Yoanna: CAMILLE AND I
ARE WALKING THE STREETS
OF VERONA OFF TO GO AND MEET
OUR ARTIST WHO WILL PAINT
OUR PORTRAITS.
LOOK AT THIS.
THANK YOU
FOR CHOOSING ME.
I FEEL SO SPECIAL.
OH, LOUIS VUITTON.
HELLO, CAMILLE.
THIS IS GORGEOUS! I LOVE IT!
♪♪♪
Yoanna: WOW.
Camille: WHAT
A BEAUTIFUL DAY.
Yoanna: MM-HMM.
Camille: I FEEL LIKE
YOANNA IS APPRECIATING THE FACT
THAT SHE'S GETTING
HER PORTRAIT DONE.
Yoanna: I JUST KEEP
LOOKING AROUND,
WANTING TO ABSORB EVERYTHING--
THE STORES, THE PEOPLE,
THE FOOD, THE BOYS.
Camille: THE BOYS.
Yoanna: AT THIS POINT,
I THINK I'M FEELING
A FRIENDSHIP WITH CAMILLE.
IT ACTUALLY ENDED UP BEING
MORE FUN THAN I THOUGHT
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN.
OH. MI GUSTA.
MI PIACE.
Man: GRAZIE.
♪♪♪
April: WE'RE OFF TO HAVE
SOME DINNER AT A QUAINT
LITTLE RESTAURANT IN VERONA.
Tyra: CIAO, BELLAS.
Women: HI.
Tyra: HI.
EVERYBODY'S HAIR
LOOKS VERY EUROPEAN.
Camille: THERE'S SOMETHING
ABOUT THESE ITALIAN MEN.
LIKE, WHEN THEY LOOK AT YOU,
IT'S LIKE THEY HAVE SUCH A...
Tyra: I TOLD YOU.
Camille: YOU JUST HEAR
VIOLINS ALL OF A SUDDEN.
I'M JUST LIKE...
Tyra: AND IT'S INTERESTING,
BECAUSE THE AMERICANS--
WE DISCARD OUR WOMEN
AFTER, LIKE, AGE 40.
THEY'RE "MATURE."
THEY CAN'T
GET ACTING PARTS.
THEY CAN'T MODEL NO MORE.
BUT HERE, THE WOMAN MATURES,
AND SHE'S STILL
AMAZINGLY BEAUTIFUL.
Jay: YOU GUYS NEVER EVEN
TOLD ME ABOUT YOUR TRIP
OR YOUR APARTMENT AT ALL.
Mercedes: OH, YEAH.
Yoanna: WE OPENED THE DOOR.
FIRST, IT DIDN'T REGISTER
WHAT WAS HAPPENING
UNTIL THIS MORNING,
AND WE WOKE UP,
AND WE WERE LIKE,
"LOOK WHERE WE'RE STAYING."
Jay: DO YOU GUYS
HAVE SEPARATE ROOMS,
OR WHAT'S THE DEAL?
April: TWO ROOMS.
Jay: TWO BEDROOMS.
Yoanna: EBONY AND IVORY
IN ONE ROOM.
Jay: EBONY AND IVORY.
Mercedes: WE ARE LIKE
A WHOLE FAMILY NOW.
I LIKE THAT.
Camille: ASK HER
WHEN SHE COMES BACK.
Jay: MM. WHY?
Camille: SHE JUST WENT
TO THE BATHROOM.
Jay: DOES SHE ALWAYS
DISAPPEAR TO THE BATHROOM
AFTER DINNER?
Shandi: WHAT? NO.
Mercedes: NO.
Camille: SHE, YOU KNOW,
DISAPPEARS AND...
Tyra: AFTER EVERY MEAL?
Camille: NO,
NOT AFTER EVERY MEAL.
JUST, SHE GOES
TO THE BATHROOM A LOT.
Tyra: WELL,
THE EATING DISORDER THING
IS VERY SENSITIVE TO ME.
I'VE NEVER EXPERIENCED IT
PERSONALLY, BUT I KNOW
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT--
April: I HAD A FRIEND THAT--
Tyra: SO IF YOU GUYS--
JUST KEEP AN EYE ON THAT.
YOU KNOW, IF YOU CAN WATCH HER
FOR ME.
Mercedes: IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WHAT GETS SAID
AT THAT TABLE WHEN TYRA IS THERE
IS THE TRUTH
AND NOTHING BUT THE TRUTH.
I THINK, YOU KNOW,
CAMILLE INSINUATED THAT
YOANNA HAS AN EATING DISORDER,
WHICH IS NOT TRUE.
Tyra: OH, YOU WERE SMOKIN'.
Yoanna: NO,
BUT I TOOK THESE FOR A MEMORY.
Tyra: OH. I WAS LIKE,
"WHERE DID THIS GIRL GO?"
ALL RIGHT, EVERYBODY, I'M FULL.
Mercedes: THANK YOU.
All: GOOD NIGHT.
Tyra: CIAO, BELLAS.
CIAO, BELLAS. (blows kisses)
Mercedes: BUT YOU UNDERSTAND
EVERYTHING, RIGHT?
ONE THING LED TO ANOTHER.
I TOLD YOANNA BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK THAT IT'S RIGHT
FOR PEOPLE TO TALK
BEHIND HER BACK.
I WAS JUST CONCERNED.
I SAW TYRA AND JAY...
Yoanna: I'M INFURIATED
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
THAT WOULD PLANT A SEED
IN TYRA'S HEAD.
YOU SAID IT IN FRONT
OF TYRA BANKS.
Camille: OH, MY GOD.
Yoanna: WHAT DID YOU
JUST SAY?
WHAT DID YOU JUST SAY?
Camille: JAY AND TYRA SAID
DO YOU--"DOES YOANNA, LIKE,
GO OFF ON HER OWN, LIKE, OFTEN?"
AND I WAS
JUST LIKE, SOMETIMES.
Yoanna: YOU SAID IT
IN FRONT OF JAY AND TYRA BANKS.
Camille: OH, MY GOD.
Yoanna: I'VE NEVER IN MY LIFE
HAD AN EATING DISORDER.
MY BODY'S A TEMPLE,
AND I'M NOT GONNA ABUSE IT
LIKE THAT.
Mercedes: CAMILLE,
YOU WERE SITTING HERE LIKE THIS,
AND JAY SAID, "YOU KNOW..."
Camille: DOES SHE
DISAPPEAR A LOT?
Mercedes: AND YOU WERE
LIKE THIS...
Camille: NO, HE DIDN'T SAY,
"DOES SHE HAVE
A EATING DISORDER?"
HE SAID, "DOES SHE
DISAPPEAR A LOT?"
"DOES YOANNA GET UP
AND GO TO THE BATHROOM
AND DISAPPEAR A LOT?"
Mercedes: OBVIOUSLY,
THE UNDERLYING THING IS THAT SHE
HAS AN EATING DISORDER. DUH.
Camille: THE QUESTION WAS
IF SHE DISAPPEARS A LOT,
AND, YES, SHE DOES DISAPPEAR
A LOT.
Yoanna: CAMILLE, DO YOU
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A MODELING
THING, AND FOR SOMEONE TO COME
OUT AND SAY THAT YOANNA MIGHT
HAVE AN EATING DISORDER--
Camille: I DID NOT SAY THAT.
Yoanna: OR HAVE IT INFERRED.
Mercedes: SHE DID NOT SAY
THAT.
Camille: I DID NOT SAY THAT.
TYRA SAID THAT
AND JAY SAID THAT,
AND I WAS JUST LIKE...
Yoanna: I'M CRUSHED THAT
SHE WOULD BRING THAT UP
BEHIND MY BACK.
NOW I HAVE TO FIX IT.
HEY, TYRA.
Tyra: HEY.
Yoanna: THERE WAS
A POSSIBLE DISCUSSION
OF A EATING DISORDER, AND THINGS
GOT WAY OUT OF CONTROL.
Tyra: ONE OF YOUR ROOMMATES
MADE A FACE.
Yoanna: THAT'S WHAT I HEARD.
Tyra: AND WE WERE LIKE,
"WHAT DO YOU MEAN?"
Yoanna: CAMILLE MADE A FACE.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT HURT ME
THE MOST.
Tyra: YOU REALLY NEED
TO STAND UP FOR YOURSELF.
MY MOM CALLS IT THE UGLY SIDE OF
THE BEAUTIFUL MODELING INDUSTRY.
EVEN THOUGH I SAW THERE WAS
A LITTLE BIT OF MAYBE
SABOTAGE IN IT,
IT DID RAISE CONCERN, YOU KNOW,
BECAUSE I WANT YOU
TO BE HEALTHY.
Yoanna: OH, YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
Tyra: I WANT EVERYONE
TO BE HEALTHY.
Yoanna: ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR YOUR ADVICE. OKAY.
OBVIOUSLY, CAMILLE CREATED
SOMETHING OUT OF NOTHING.
I'VE QUESTIONED
CAMILLE'S MOTIVES FROM DAY ONE.
I WAS RIGHT. IT'S OVER.
GUYS, WE HAVE MAIL.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY FOUR OF YOU WILL
CONTINUE ON WITH THE HOPE
OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED."
Mercedes: I JUST HOPE
THAT MY PICTURES CAME OUT GOOD,
BECAUSE I REALLY WANNA STAY
IN ITALY.
YEAH, IT'S NOT FAIR
FOR ME TO ONLY BE HERE TWO DAYS
AND THEN GO HOME.
Yoanna: I MIGHT NOT BE
THE SHANDI SIZE,
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT I CAN'T DO MODELING.
HOPEFULLY, THE JUDGES KNOW THAT.
♪♪♪
Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS
FOR GETTING THIS FAR
ALL THE WAY TO EUROPE.
NOW IT'S TIME TO MAKE
OUR EIGHTH CUT TOWARDS
DETERMINING WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WE'VE GOT SOME PRIZES--
A CONTRACT WITH IMG,
ONE OF THE TOP MANAGEMENT
COMPANIES IN THE WORLD,
A FASHION SPREAD
IN "JANE" MAGAZINE
AND A COSMETICS CAMPAIGN
WITH SEPHORA.
NOW WE'RE GONNA INTRODUCE
OUR JUDGES.
FIRST, WE HAVE MISS JANICE
"SILVER DRESS" DICKINSON.
Janice: THE WORLD'S
FIRST SUPERMODELA.
Tyra: WE HAVE ERIC NICHOLSON.
ERIC IS
THE SENIOR FASHION EDITOR
AT "JANE" MAGAZINE.
(British accent)
WE HAVE NIGEL BARKER.
HE'S A NOTED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
(normal voice) AND AS YOU CAN
SEE ALL THE WAY OVER HERE...
(Italian accent)
MR. MICHAEL GIANNINI.
(normal voice) MICHAEL WAS
AT ONE OF YOUR GO-SEES.
Michael: (speaking Italian)
NO, NO, NO, NO.
Tyra: HIS NAME MIGHT BE
(Italian accent)
MICHAEL GIANNINI,
(New York accent) BUT HE TALKS
JUST LIKE ME AND YOU.
(normal voice) HE IS AMERICAN.
HE IS NOT ITALIAN,
AND HE HAPPENS TO BE ONE
OF MY AGENTS AT D'MANAGEMENT.
Michael: (American accent)
HELLO, LADIES.
Janice: (laughing)
Michael: WHEN YOU MEET
PEOPLE AT GO-SEES,
IT'S CRITICAL THAT YOU
COME ACROSS AS PROFESSIONAL
AND CONFIDENT.
THE OTHER DAY WHEN YOU MET
LILIANA AND ME, IT WASN'T
JUST AN ORDINARY GO-SEE.
IT WAS ACTUALLY A TEST.
WE WERE PURPOSELY
AND PARTICULARLY
HARD ON YOU GUYS--APOLOGIES--
'CAUSE WE NEEDED TO SEE
YOUR REACTION.
WE PUT TOGETHER VIDEO CLIPS
OF THAT GO-SEE.
Tyra: AND, SHANDI...
YOU'RE FIRST.
COME ON, SHANDI.
Michael: THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME THAT ANY
OF THE JUDGES ARE GONNA BE
SEEING THIS VIDEO CLIP, OKAY?
SHANDI, LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY GOT ON YOU.
(Italian accent) OKAY, GO.
Janice: LOOK AT SHANDI WALK!
Michael: WHY SHOULD SHE
TAKE YOU WITH AS LITTLE
EXPERIENCE LIKE YOU DO?
WHY? PLEASE EXPLAIN WHY.
Shandi: UM, ONE THING
THAT I WOULD THINK OF
IS ESPECIALLY BY LOOKING
AT MY PICTURES,
IF SHE WERE TO SEE
SOMETHING IN ME,
LIKE IN MY PHOTOGRAPHS...
Eric: BRAVA.
Janice: SHANDI, YOU RESPONDED
HONESTLY FROM YOUR HEART.
I LOVE THE WAY YOU DEALT
WITH HIS BIZARRE QUESTIONS.
Michael: (normal voice)
YOUR SHYNESS REALLY, REALLY
CAME OUT.
Nigel: AND I THINK
MICHAEL'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
IN WHAT HE'S SAYING.
WHAT HE DOESN'T KNOW
IS THE JOURNEY YOU'VE TAKEN
THAT WE'VE SEEN.
FROM THERE TO HERE--
IT'S AN ENORMOUS IMPROVEMENT.
Tyra: YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: THIS IS
PERFECTION PERSONIFIED.
I'M CRAZY ABOUT IT.
Nigel: AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOUR LONG LIMBS REALLY WORK
VERY WELL.
Tyra: THE PHOTOGRAPHER
GAVE NOTES ON EVERYONE.
NOT ONLY WERE YOU
HIS HANDS DOWN FAVORITE GIRL,
YOURS WERE SOME
OF THE BEST PHOTOGRAPHS
HE'S TAKEN ALL YEAR.
Shandi: WHOA.
Eric: WOW! WOW.
Tyra: MERCEDES.
Janice: (Italian accent)
MERCEDES.
Michael: (Italian accent)
DO YOU ALWAYS
WALK LIKE THAT OR...
Mercedes: YEAH, I DO.
I TEND TO WALK WITH MY HIPS
STRAIGHT FORWARD.
Liliana: HOW OLD ARE YOU?
Mercedes: I'M 22.
Liliana: 22? OH.
Janice: I WOULD'VE SLAPPED
THAT WOMAN'S FACE
IF SHE TALKED TO ME LIKE THAT.
Tyra: AND YOU WOULD BE
HOMELESS AND JOBLESS.
THE ONE THING I WANTED TO
TELL YOU THAT I NOTICED
THAT WAS NEGATIVE IS SHE SAID,
"DO YOU ALWAYS WALK LIKE THIS?"
YOU SHOULD'VE SAID,
"NO. I WILL WALK
HOWEVER YOU WANT ME TO WALK."
Janice: THAT'S TRUE.
Tyra: BECAUSE RIGHT THEN
AND THERE, THAT CLIENT IS GOING,
"OH, SHE CAN ONLY WALK
LIKE THAT? NEXT."
Janice: YOU LOOK LIKE
A WARRIOR.
IT'S REALLY GOOD.
Eric: YOUR BODY IS DOING
THIS HIGH FASHION AWKWARD POSE,
BUT YOUR FACE IS JUST
SORT OF NORMAL.
Tyra: THE PHOTOGRAPHER SAID
HE HAD THE GREATEST CONNECTION
WITH YOU, BUT THAT YOUR LOOK WAS
A LITTLE COMMERCIAL FOR HIM.
Michael: (normal voice)
I THINK SHE IS COMMERCIAL.
Tyra: MISS CAMILLE.
Michael: OKAY, GIRL,
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR CLIP.
Janice: THIS I GOTTA SEE.
Camille: (chuckles)
Michael: (Italian accent)
OKAY, SHE WANTS TO KNOW
WHY YOU WALK LIKE THIS.
Camille: THIS IS
MY SIGNATURE WALK,
AND THIS IS WHAT'S GOING TO
MAKE ME FAMOUS.
ACTUALLY, I'M HERE BECAUSE
I GOT CHOSEN OUT OF 6,000 GIRLS
AND 12 WERE CHOSEN
FOR "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
Tyra: I HAVE TO DO A JANICE.
Eric: OOH!
Janice: CAMILLE,
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING?
Nigel: TIME AND TIME AGAIN,
WE'VE TALKED TO YOU ABOUT
ATTITUDE.
Tyra: YOU KNOW WHAT IT
LOOKED LIKE TO ME WHEN YOU
RAN OFF THE WHOLE
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"?
"LOOK, BITCH, YOU KNOW, I WAS
CHOSEN OVER A MILLION PEOPLE,
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOUR PROBLEM IS."
Camille: WHEN
THE GO-SEE PROCESS WAS OVER,
UM, I WON THE AWARD FOR--
Tyra: YEAH, THEY SAID YOU
PRESENTED YOURSELF VERY WELL,
BUT THIS IS A TEST
SEPARATE FROM YOUR GO-SEES.
THIS WAS A TEST
OF A GO-SEE FROM HELL.
Michael: (normal voice)
TRY TO WORK ON HUMILITY
A LITTLE BIT.
Janice: YOU HAVE
A BEAUTIFUL NECK.
HERE, YOUR HAIR IS ALL OVER
THE NECKLINE.
YOU ARE PIGEON-TOED HERE.
I JUST KNOW THAT
THAT YOU CAN DO BETTER.
Eric: YOU CAN DO BETTER.
Nigel: YOU'VE DONE BETTER.
Tyra: THE PHOTOGRAPHER SAID
CAMILLE WAS BY FAR
HIS LEAST FAVORITE GIRL.
HE SAID SHE NEEDED TO BE
MORE IN TOUCH
WITH HER HEART AND SOUL.
NEXT IS YOANNA.
Liliana: (speaking Italian)
Michael: (Italian accent)
SHE'S ASKING YOU
IF YOU'VE DONE--YOU DO--
Yoanna: NO, MA'AM,
I'M JUST STARTING OUT.
Michael: HOW CAN
YOUR PRESENCE DO US TO SELL?
PLEASE EXPLAIN.
Yoanna: WELL, UM,
I'M BASICALLY--I MEAN,
I HAVE A CLASSIC LOOK AND--
Liliana: GRAZIE.
Michael: OKAY, THANK YOU.
Tyra: I THOUGHT YOU LOOKED
ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
Eric: OH! BE STILL.
Tyra: AND, LIKE, YOU WERE
STRIKING THESE POSES
THAT WEREN'T--
YOU DIDN'T KNOW YOU WERE.
I WAS LIKE,
DAMN, THAT'S A PICTURE.
Michael: (normal voice)
YOU DIDN'T GET AGGRESSIVE
NOR BACK DOWN, BECAUSE I WAS
REALLY HARD ON YOU.
Janice: THAT DOESN'T EVEN
LOOK LIKE YOU, GIRL.
IT'S FANTASTIC.
IT'S GREAT BODY LANGUAGE.
Nigel: YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT'S ANOTHER LOOK
THAT I HAVEN'T SEEN OF YOU,
WHICH IS GREAT.
Janice: GOOD JOB.
Tyra: APRIL'S NEXT.
Michael: (Italian accent)
WHY SHOULD SHE TAKE YOU?
PLEASE EXPLAIN,
AND DON'T JUST SAY
BECAUSE YOU ARE PRETTY.
OKAY? PLEASE EXPLAIN.
Janice: (laughing)
April: IF SHE TELLS ME
WHAT SHE WANTS,
FROM EMOTION IN MY FACE--
Michael: SHE DON'T WANT YOU
TO THINK TOO MUCH.
EXPLAIN WHY YOU NEED TO GO INTO
THIS, UH, EXPLANATION.
Tyra: ONE THING
YOU HAVE TO REALIZE IS
THE FASHION INDUSTRY--
IT'S ROMANTIC, IT'S ARTISTIC,
IT'S ALL ABOUT EMOTION.
IT'S VERY--IT'S LESS CLINICAL.
Nigel: YOU HAD
SOME OF THE BEST ANSWERS,
BUT WHAT YOU SHOULD DO IS
WHEN YOU DELIVER THOSE ANSWERS,
PURR.
Tyra: THINK EARTHA KITT.
(purrs)
ALL RIGHT,
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Eric: FOR ME,
IT LOOKED LIKE A CORPSE
IN THE FACE.
Nigel: I DON'T REALLY
SEE THAT, ACTUALLY.
I LIKE THE INTENSITY.
Janice: THIS PHOTOGRAPH
LOOKS LIKE THE BATTERIES DIED
IN HER VIBRATOR.
Eric: EW. (chuckles)
Tyra: SHANDI.
Janice: THIS GIRL
IS A SUPERMODEL IN THE MAKING.
Nigel: THE PROBLEM I HAVE
WITH SHANDI IS SHE NEEDS
TO FOCUS MORE AND BE MORE
SORT OF SECURE WITH HERSELF.
Tyra: YOANNA.
Janice: YOANNA HAS EMERGED
FROM QUIRK NERD
TO ELEGANT MODEL.
Nigel: I'VE HAD A PROBLEM
WITH YOANNA OVER THE WEEKS,
AND I KEEP SAYING SHE'S GOT
THIS GREAT FACE, GREAT FACE,
BUT THE BODY ISN'T WORKING
FOR ME.
THIS IS A SHOT FOR ME
WHERE THE WHOLE THING WORKS.
Tyra: I LOVE THIS PHOTO
OF APRIL.
I THINK SHE LOOKS
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
Michael: I THINK
APRIL HAS FIERCE EYES.
SHE HAS FIERCE LIPS.
Eric: SHE'S THINKING
INSTEAD OF FEELING IT.
Tyra: CAMILLE.
Nigel: CAMILLE--
WHAT ON EARTH IS SHE DOING?
SHE JUST HAS TO LOSE
THE ATTITUDE.
Eric: SHE HAS
ALL THIS ENERGY,
THIS AGGRESSIVE ENERGY
WHICH COULD BE CHANNELED
INTO SUCH A SUCCESSFUL CAREER.
Tyra: MERCEDES.
Janice: IT'S ALMOST AN "A,"
THIS SHOT ON MERCEDES.
Michael: I LIKE HOW MERCEDES
PRESENTS HERSELF.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT NECESSARILY
IS SOMETHING THAT CAN TAKE
SOMEONE TO HIGH LEVELS.
Eric: SHE WAS WEARING
AN AMAZING JOHN GALLIANO DRESS,
BUT SHE DOESN'T TAKE YOU THERE
ALL THE WAY.
SHE TAKES YOU
TO THE KNOCKOFF VERSION
OF JOHN GALLIANO.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT,
WE'VE REACHED A DECISION.
Tyra: I HAVE FIVE YOUNG WOMEN
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE FOUR PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE FOUR PHOTOS
REPRESENT THE FOUR OF YOU THAT
WILL STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Tyra: SHANDI.
THIS PICTURE IS AN AD,
BUT WE NEED OUR GIRL
NOT TO JUST LOOK FIERCE.
WE NEED HER TO BE FIERCE,
TO SHOW THAT SHE HAS SOME FIRE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOANNA.
YOANNA, EVERY MODEL HAS
SOMETHING THAT THEY
JUST HAVE TO HIDE.
IT'S YOUR JOB TO CONCEAL IT,
AND YOU DID AN AMAZING JOB HERE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
APRIL.
APRIL, YOU ARE SO TECHNICAL,
BUT IF YOU WANNA MODEL,
JUST RELAX AND EXHALE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WILL MERCEDES AND CAMILLE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
Tyra: CAMILLE,
YOU ARE UNDENIABLY BEAUTIFUL.
I ONCE TOLD YOU
THAT WE WANT YOU HERE,
AND FOR SOME REASON,
YOU FEEL LIKE YOU STILL NEED
TO PROVE TO THE WORLD
THAT YOU'RE GOOD ENOUGH.
CAMILLE, YOU ARE GOOD ENOUGH.
MERCEDES, YOU'RE HERE
BECAUSE OF YOUR PERSONALITY.
THERE WERE TAPES OF GIRLS
THAT I SAW THAT WERE
SO AMAZINGLY BEAUTIFUL,
BUT YOU HAVE A FIRE AND A DRIVE.
THERE'S A LITTLE
SOMETHING EXTRA,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
THERE IS THAT COMMERCIAL THING
THAT MAKES THE JUDGES GO,
"BUT WILL THE FASHION INDUSTRY
BELIEVE IT?"
Tyra: MAYBE THE WORLD
WILL BELIEVE IT, MERCEDES.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Mercedes: THANK YOU.
♪♪♪
Camille: CIAO.
Camille: THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I WANTED, UM...
BUT... IT DIDN'T WORK OUT.
I FEEL... SAD.
I FEEL DISAPPOINTED.
I TAKE ALL THE POSITIVE
FROM IT.
I TAKE ALL THE CRITICISM,
AND I'M GOING TO USE THAT
TO MAKE CAMILLE
A BETTER CAMILLE.
♪♪♪
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
HERE'S WHAT'S COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
A VISIT FROM
SOME LOCAL ITALIAN MEN
LEADS TO A DEVASTATING CRISIS
FOR SHANDI.
April: SHE'S FEELING
EXTREME GUILT.
Shandi: I WANNA DIE.
I JUST LET IT HAPPEN.
Eric: You had sex?!
Oh, my God.
Shandi: I'M SORRY, HONEY.
Eric: (shrieking)
What were you thinking?!
Shandi: AND I JUST
WANNA GO HOME.
YOU SHUT UP.
♪♪♪